hay una película muy popular y en mi
opinión buena basada en la obra que toma
como referencia a la novela de víctor
hugo
lenis abal y estoy segura de que le
estoy pronunciando mal los miserables
para aquellos que no me entendieron y lo
que quiero darte es un poco de contexto
porque en ese libro obra película hay un
intento de revolución y muchas veces las
personas suelen asociarlo con la
revolución francesa pero la obra de los
miserables no está representando la
revolución francesa a la que la gente se
refiere cuando habla de la revolución
francesa así que pensé en exponerte a un
poco de historia francesa desde finales
de los 1700 hasta mediados de 1800 para
darte un poco de contexto del tema
empecemos en 1789
y 789 aquí tenemos a la revolución
francesa
podríamos decir la primera red
acción
o la revolución francesa de la que la
gente habla cuando se refiere a la
revolución francesa todo giraba
alrededor de destituir a luís 16 y a su
esposa maría antonieta aquí está su
cuerpo
creo que la acaban de decapitar esta es
su cabeza fue una revolución muy
sanguinaria ésta es la toma de la paz
ya
y eso pone en marcha el inicio de la
primera república en francia la primera
república estaban todos estos sueños y
aspiraciones de que francia fuera ahora
un país del pueblo no muy distinto a los
eeuu pero las revoluciones no son tan
fáciles ni tan simples ni tan rápidas y
francia tuvo que enfrentar un largo
período de dolor antes de realmente
poder establecerse como una verdadera
república pero ahora vayamos más
adelante en la historia haré una línea
de tiempo en blanco avancemos rápido en
el tiempo hasta 1799
1799 esto es cuando napoleón bonaparte
llega al poder cuando la gente habla de
napoleón está hablando de napoleón
bonaparte veremos que hay otros
napoleones pero cuando la gente dice que
napoleón hizo esto o aquello están
hablando de napoleón bonaparte aquí es
cuando napoleón llega al poder
y el oficialmente acaba con la primera
república en 1804 porque se declara a sí
mismo emperador pero volvamos a avanzar
rápidamente en el tiempo hay muchos
vídeos en khan academy que tratan de las
guerras napoleónicas y de la revolución
francesa avancemos hasta 1815 llegamos a
1815 aquí avanzamos como diez años ahora
nos adelantaremos dieciséis años
aquí tenemos 1815 justo aquí
y es esencialmente cuando un apoyo a una
enfrenta a su waterloo que ocurrió
injustamente en waterloo eso es a lo que
la gente se refiere con la frase
enfrentar tu propio waterloo después fue
exiliado a la isla de elba por un tiempo
y al tiempo pudo regresar estuvo cien
de hecho 111 días en el poder pero
después finalmente fue derrotado y
exiliado a la isla santa elena donde
murió en 1815 esencialmente se tiene en
la restauración de la monarquía
borbónica el hermano pequeño de louis 16
llega al poder y lo llamaron luis 18
louis
esto trae una muy buena pregunta qué
pasó con louis 17
louis 17 fue el hijo de louis 16 que
murió en prisión a los 10 años
en 1795 durante la revolución
y creo que podríamos decir durante el
periodo revolucionario esto de aquí
desde 1799 hasta
hasta de hecho 1814
que fue cuando terminó el reino de
napoleón pero luego regresó un momento
así que dibujar una línea punteada aquí
y luego en 1814 fue la restauración
formal de la monarquía borbónica y
después napoleón regresa por un momento
pero después de waterloo está realmente
firmemente establecida tiene la
restauración de la monarquía borbónica
aquí entra louis 18 luego en 1824 él
muere y muere sin hijos
1824 pasaron nueve años justo año 1824
muere sin hijos por lo que su hermano
menor carlos décimo llegó al poder luego
tiene sal
carlos
escribiré a todos los borbones en morado
carlos décimo je
y este de aquí es carlos décimo ahora
avanzamos un poco más en la historia
hasta llegar a 1830
y ahora tienes la segunda revolución
francesa podrías decir oye esto es de lo
que tratan los miserables pero no
estamos ahí aún los miserables no toman
parte de la segunda revolución francesa
esto algunas veces se conoce como la
revolución de julio
luz visión
d
y esta revolución de hecho fue exitosa
pero no se estableció una república esta
vez y todo este tiempo hubo un tipo de
liberación la monarquía aunque estuviera
en el poder tuvo un decremento gradual
en la cantidad de poder que tenía pero
después de la revolución de julio
pusieron al primo de carlos decimos que
es el duque de orleans
este hombre de aquí luis felipe primero
déjame escribir esto es
louis
en
luego
y ahora dices oye empezaste este vídeo
hablando de los miserables y no has
mencionado a los miserables aún también
un poco de contexto y ahora te voy a dar
el contexto si viste la película verás
que empieza con jean valjean que está en
un puerto donde hay barcos de algún tipo
eso fue en 1815 después de waterloo fue
bajo el régimen de luis 18 eso fue justo
aquí el inicio de la película es justo
ahí y luego el clímax real de la
película donde hay esta rebelión estas
barricadas que tuvieron lugar en parís
donde todos estos personajes idealistas
intentaban derrocar al gobierno esto no
ocurrió hasta 1832 aquí está
1832 justo aquí
y lo que detonó eso o varias cosas que
detonaron eso fueron y
y de hecho la mayoría de las
revoluciones son originadas debido a
solo descontentos económicos si las
personas son felices y ricas y tienen
trabajos y no se enferman la mayoría de
la gente no tiene ganas de hacer una
revolución pero en 1832 como te lo
puedes imaginar la situación económica
no era buena había un feo brote de
cólera
y lo que realmente catalizó los eventos
en los miserables y a lo que hacen
referencia en la película es la muerte
de este sujeto justo aquí jan maximilian
lema que déjame escribir lo son
mack sin
lean
martes
y estoy segura de que lo estoy
pronunciando mal y bueno él muere en
junio
1832 y era muy compasivo a la situación
de los pobres ya la de los hombres
comunes y los de clase media decía ese
es nuestro hombre en el gobierno tiene
un rol influyente en el gobierno cuando
él murió dijeron que no tenemos a nadie
más en una posición alta que pueda
hablar por nosotros utilicemos su
funeral como un catalizador para una
rebelión y viste eso pasar en la
película de los miserables en los
miserables el momento de clímax fue la
rebelión de junio de 1832 y no debes de
tener una increíble comprensión al ver
películas para darte cuenta que esto no
tuvo éxito estuve aquí
yo
no funcionó si hubiera funcionado se
hubiera llamado la tercera revolución
francesa pero no lo fue fue una
revolución sin éxito una rebelión sin
éxito de hecho
y víctor hugo la observo y es por eso
que pudo volver a contarla con tantos
detalles las marcadas la gente joven los
tiroteos en las calles y todo el resto
hagamos un breve resumen cuando la gente
habla de la revolución francesa
usualmente hablan de la revolución
francesa de 1789 donde se establece o se
comienza a establecer la primera
república fue una revolución exitosa la
segunda revolución francesa
esta es la revolución de julio
esta es en 1830 es cuando llega al poder
luis felipe primero la persona a la que
intentan derrocar en los miserables y no
establece en la segunda república
después de esto para la segunda
república tenemos que ir hasta la
revolución de y continuaré mi línea de
tiempo aquí entra luis felipe y tenemos
que avanzar 18 años hasta 1848 donde
tienes la tercera revolución francesa la
será re
sesión
esa
que nos lleva a la elección popular del
sobrino de napoleón bonaparte el sobrino
de napoleón bonaparte luis napoleón
bonaparte este personaje de aquí pero
francia aún no podía establecerse como
una república duradera en 1851
este personaje se declaró a sí mismo
emperador en 1851 este clara emperador y
francia no está aún libre de reyes y
emperadores hasta 1870 hasta 1870
avancemos en el tiempo hasta
1870 donde francia de hecho pierde la
guerra franco-prusiana y este personaje
de aquí es derrocado y se establece la
tercera república francesa